I spoke to Suzy that's my mom she cuz
what are you gonna settle down and start
a family I said never
she said why I said cuz I woke up this
morning had to feed one person me
and guess what Suzy I forgot it's not
too bright
my girlfriend's bright she's smart she's
an epidemiologist and I'm a stand-up
comedian so that makes me one charming
son of a baby who's got some chores to
do when he gets home if you don't know
what an epidemiologist is that's all
right I looked it up and I can
confidently tell you I can't spell
epidemiologist a lot of eyes and ease in
weird places I just found out green
onions and scallions are the same thing
for those of you didn't laugh at that
now you know I got sent to the store
with a list top of the list scallions as
I walked in had an honest moth myself
like I have no idea what scallions look
like I think I do but I know I don't and
I did two laps around the produce
section and see the word scallions
anywhere and I'm convincing myself there
in jars I can see it's like relish
jalopy nose scallions you guys see it
they float and I'm about to head over to
the pickle aisle and I stopped the guy
stocking produce just a double check I
walked up I said uh
hey handsome where are the scallions and
he stains up because sir green onions
right over there by the bell peppers and
then he went back to work like he just
did not answer a question I did not ask
[Music]
it's like a produce Jedi mind-trick it
almost work I said right now man green
onions thanks I wait a damn minute hey
handsome wear this I said scallions stew
trying to get me jammed up I'll walk
back over I said I'm sorry dude
where are the scallions and he has sir
green onions right over there by the
bell peppers I said all right player
that's what I thought you said green
onions by the bell peppers
noted hey dude where the hell are the
scallions man and he goes sir the green
onions are right over I was like what is
with you in the green onions dude he
said green onions and scallions are the
same thing I said nonsense prove it he
said I don't have to prove it I'd know
it I said dude are you trying to get me
jammed up he said sir is like is this a
conspiracy he said sir I was like are
you messing with me dude he said sir
have no reason to mess with you it was
like quit calling me sir and you were
gonna pick and save you have every
reason to mess with me by the bell
peppers he's like sir pointing right at
them I was like I walked on the other
side of the produce section I was like
scallions he goes yes green onions I
said no say scallions because my
girlfriend would be the one coming back
and I promise you I'm the pleasant one
we have to get this right you and I have
to get this right now what am i pointing
at and he said scallions I said thank
you and I grabbed a whole armful because
it said we need a bunch and I don't know
how much a bunch is
I know I'm not coming back and I get
everything else on the list and I'm
standing there in the checkout line
wrapping my head around this paradox
I've been eating green onions I'm a
baked potato this whole time yuck
and that got tapped on the shoulder
behind me this little old lady behind me
she goes are you a vegetarian and I
stood there trying to remember what I
look like
I don't want to have this conversation
so I've turned I said ma'am I don't even
wear condoms she said excuse me I said
did you know green onions and scallions
are the same thing
she said you means spring onions I said
lady what the hell is your problem back
off and I got home and I called Susie
back up and I said hey she goes what I
said you know green onions and scallions
are the same thing she said of course I
said so it is a conspiracy
she said why is it cuz I just learned
this and she said Oh said honey maybe
you shouldn't be having kids it's like
thanks mom you guys were a lot of fun
Thanks
[Applause]
you